une chape de silence comme si l'hôpital
de belfort montbéliard se contractait
tout entier autour d'une étrange affaire
d'empoisonnement les faits datent de
juin 2019 avant la crise du coc vide et
touchent directement le service de
réanimation
une aide soignante est soupçonné d'avoir
drogué ses collègues grâce à une
substance introduite dans les boissons
se sentant faible sans explication une
infirmière décident d'installer un
téléphone portable près du frigo de
service les choses sont claires
elle a filmé de manière formelle cette
personne en train incorporels seringue
un produit
il semblerait que les expertises
toxicologiques qui ont été faites sur
les cheveux de ma cliente permettent de
démontrer qu'elle a été exposée un
neuroleptique assez puissant à ce jour
une dizaine de salariés sur les 95
travail en réanimation aurait porté
plainte contre leur ancien collègue
dans un communiqué l'hôpital précise que
l'agent suspecté a été exclu de
l'établissement et que les soignants
concernés ont été accompagnés sur le
plan psychologique
mais quatorze mois après le dépôt de
plainte ces salariés n'ont toujours pas
de nouvelles de la justice
pire ils soupçonnent l'aide soignante de
travailler à nouveau alors ai appris que
la mise en cous travaillerait
aujourd'hui admis dans un établissement
de soins privés imaginez si c'est exact
c'est à dire que le silence du ministère
public
l'absence de réaction peut actuellement
faire courir un risque important à
d'autres personnes l'enquète est loin
d'être close d'autant qu'on apprenait ce
matin l'existence d'un nouveau cas
mortel celui ci celui d'une aide
soignante qui en janvier 2019 au retour
d'une nuit travail à l'hôpital a perdu
la vie à bord de son véhicule qui avait
chuté dans la rivière la savoureuse
alors cette femme travaillait dans
plusieurs services à la fois dont un
très proche de la réanimation l'hôpital
refusent d'établir tout lien avec les
cas cités précédemment
mais beaucoup de salariés du service de
réanimation évoque des accidents
matériels suite à des assouplissements
ou des pertes de connaissance
le mari de sept salariés décédés a
décidé de porter plainte contre x